New York Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman is not the new york stock
exchange in these joining me now
attorney general thank you for being
here talk to me first about exactly how
this is going to get structured 800
million of the roughly 17 billion
dollars worth of fines is going to go to
New York yes we were getting 300 million
in cash but we have a minimum of 500
million in consumer relief and the
consumer relief that's being offered in
the bank of america settlement is really
much it's a much broader set of menu
items than there was any there were
neither the chase or the city deals and
we expect in New York to do much better
than the 500 million which the bank is
obliged to provide us and we've done
better in previous settlements when they
did the first national mortgage
servicing settlement HUD estimated that
New York families would get about six
hundred million dollars worth of
principal reduction and other relief we
got over two billion dollars because
we've set up what I think is the best
network in the country of legal services
and housing counselors to help people
who are eligible for programs know what
programs they're eligible for you
mentioned legal services and and
counseling programs for housing I mean
one of the fears here attorney
Schneiderman is that all this money gets
paid to the government and it doesn't
actually get back to the people who need
it most or who may have been victims
from this kind of fraud what actually
happens to it in terms of the consumers
that might need it will they see
anything sure the consumers are saying
it the the network of legal services and
housing counselors is set up because
these are people who know what consumers
are eligible for if I'm an average
homeowner there may be a federal
modification program available there may
be a bank modification program I won't
know about it it's hard to tell these
legal services and housing counseling
folks over 90 agencies around the state
are they've already helped more than
30,000 New York families figure out what
they were eligible for and they provide
legitimate advice I have to say there
also is the sub industry of scammers who
are pretending they will help New
Yorkers and others in other parts of the
country get their mortgages redone we're
getting people's mortgages written down
principal reductions rate reductions all
over the state of New York and this
money just started flowing in the last
year or so you're going to see a lot of
relief to a lot of homeowners and in
state of New York we're not just dealing
with individual homeowners were also
funding land banks to help communities
where you have a lot of abandoned
properties that bring down the property
values ruin the tax base we're helping
the people who were really hit by the
crash has sort of collateral damage they
didn't get foreclosed on themselves but
because their communities were
devastated their suffering too so this
is a comprehensive approach and in our
office we have an open request for
proposal process and rfp process for any
money we give at is all posted on our
website so the money is not sticking in
some government bureaucracy there's been
no criminal prosecution to speak of do
you regret that um I think that if
things had gotten started a little bit
earlier there might have been some
criminal cases to be made i think that
when i came in in january 2011 as the
tourney generalist started to get a
sense of what the scope of this problem
was we did the best we could i'm proud
of the fact that we fought to establish
the working group that the president set
up in january 2012 and the chase steal
the city deal and this record-breaking
deal with Bank of America are all coming
out of the work of this national working
group the President Obama set up in
January 2012 he doesn't get mentioned a
lot in these stories but he's the one
who put justice in my office and the SEC
and others together and we really
started ramping up the cases in DOJ
putting more resources and that's why
we're getting these record-breaking
attorney Sneiderman what do you say to
those who critique this and say you know
what bank of america really helped the
country at a time when it needed help
because countrywide and merrill lynch
were acquired by bank of america and as
a result a lot of the pain and suffering
that could have come with both of those
banks going under did not happen what do
you say in response to this to say this
really isn't fair because this is coming
back to hurt them in the end at a time
when they were trying to help look these
are not charitable organizations I have
very high regard for the management
bank of america city and chase but they
made deals they thought were in their
financial interest when JP Morgan took
over Bear Stearns they were touting it
as one of the great steals of the
century it appeared to be a great deal
same thing with countrywide and bank of
america and at the end of the day these
institutions all got bailed out by the
federal government they paid back the
money but there were no strings attached
to the bailout so there was no
additional benefit the American people I
think the financial institutions did
what they had to do they're out to make
money fair enough if I buy stock in one
of these companies I want them to try
and make money for me but I don't want
them to engage in the kind of reckless
misconduct that brought the economy to
its knees but they didn't make money in
these particular cases they lost money
on all of these and then they got bailed
out and they're back in there back in
the black how many more fines do you
anticipate coming forward I mean are we
nearing the end of this cycle now with
this record-breaking nearly 17 billion
dollars well the total that we've
recovered in cash a consumer relief if
you count the chase city bank of america
and the national mortgage servicing
settlement we're up over sixty billion
dollars in cash and consumer relief as a
result of these collective efforts there
there are more institutions out there
and i'm looking forward to this and i do
have to say i think that the management
of JPMorgan Chase city in bank of
america history will look back and say
it was a smart move to get all this
behind you it all of the deals on the
table gather up every agency every state
AG that he might have a case with put it
behind you there's a piece premium for
all the banks that do the right thing
and settle and I'm glad we were able to
work this out at the bank of america
before I let you go I know you've been
looking very significantly into high
frequency trading any updates on your
hft investigations that you can share
with us right now not that I can share
with you right now but there was a
motion filed in the Barclays case that
we will be responding to early next
month okay we're gonna leave it there
thank you very much for joining me here
today from the New York Stock Exchange
Attorney General of New York Eric
Schneiderman